deux organisations revendiquent à
beyrouth la responsabilité de l'attentât
à l'explosif qui a fait un mort et 18
blessés hier soir au bureau de poste de
l'hôtel de ville de paris
michèle cotta démissionne de ses
fonctions présidente de la haute
autorité quelques semaines avant le
remplacement prévu de cette institution
par une commission nationale de la
communication et les libertés anatoly
shaanxi en direct invités de cette
édition de 20 heures l'ancien dissident
soviétique vient d'être reçu par le
président mitterrand
nous sommes le mardi 9 septembre 1986
cela fait 5 136 jours de détention pour
marcel carton et marcel fontaine
quatre cent soixante quinze jours de
détention pour jean paul kauffmann et
michel seurat 185 jours de détention
pour aurel cornéa et jean louis
normandin d'antenne 2 et 125 jours de
détention pour camille sonntag
il reste sept otages français détenus au
liban
bonsoir et j'ajouterais qu'il y à un
nouvel otages étrangers le 17e au liban
c'est un américain un directeur d'école
frank herbert président
il est âgé de 55 ans frank herbert reid
a été enlevé aujourd'hui par
l'organisation jihad islamique
toutes les recherches médicales ne sont
pas nécessairement bonnes à prolonger le
biologiste jacques testart qui travaille
avec le professeur frydman à l'hôpital
antoine béclère à clamart dans les
hauts-de-seine n'entend pas jouer les
apprentis sorciers
jacques testart grâce à ses recherches
fondamentales a permis les première
fécondation in vitro en france et très
récemment la naissance de bébés à partir
d'embryons congelés aujourd'hui ils
crient casse-cou expliquant qu'il n'y a
pas de réglementation juridique au
médical en france et que cela l'inquiète
explications lucie soboul martin alain
raynaud ces magnifiques enfants ni il ya
plusieurs années nous les appelions les
bébés de la science ils étaient les
premiers à naître par fécondation in
vitro depuis des techniques de plus en
plus sophistiquées ont permis aux
médecins de vaincre la stérilité la plus
ancienne celle insémination artificielle
avec le sperme d'un donneur anonyme
conservés dans une banque de sperme
on a ces mines l'épousé d'un homme
stérile déjà seize mille naissances en
france depuis dix ans
deuxième étape déjà classique la
fécondation in vitro les ovules d'une
femme sont prélevés ainsi que le sperme
de son mari
la fécondation a lieu en éprouvette
bilan en france plus de 300 naissances
la troisième étape est récente les
médecins qu'on gèle les embryons obtenus
après la fécondation in vitro pour les
réimplanter plus tard en france ses deux
bébés sur les premiers à mettre ainsi en
avril dernier après avoir été conservé
au stade d'embryons ces progrès
successifs ont ouvert la voie à bien
d'autres possibilités
don d'ovules et d'embryons près d'utérus
et même récemment congélation d'ovules
tout cela jacques testart continuera à y
travailler mais ce qu'il craint c'est
que l'on aille encore beaucoup plus loin
et que l'on s'éloigne de la lutte contre
la lèpre en exemple concret dans
l'immédiat dans l'est dans les décennies
à venir
c'est qu'il va y avoir une déviation un
détournement du but de la fécondation in
vitro qui était de donner un enfant un
couple stérile vers une autre approche
qui vais te donner un enfant calibre et
un couple non stériles lundi à faire des
jumeaux choisir le sexe c'est à dire
essentiellement oui ce qui me fait peur
c'est de avant de mettre un oeuvre dans
l'utérus une fois qu'il a été féconde in
vitro de choisir parmi les cinq ou six
qu'on peut avoir
produit par le même couple et à la
demande du groupe de m ceux qui sont
parents des garçons par exemple pour le
moment ça peut s'arrêter là un peu plus
tard ce pourrait être affiné
c'est à dire choisir des caractères qui
pèse parents choisir des caractères
effectivement les caractères de cet
enfant en dehors de son sexe plus
précisément concept pour lesquelles je
lis actuellement n'est pas capable mais
ça va très très vite s'il faut pour
faire un enfant quand on n'a pas besoin
du corps médical aller le consulter
quand même et aller voir des biologistes
et passer par des artifices parce que on
aura inventé un nouveau besoin qui est
d'avoir un enfant défini comme ceci ou
comme cela je crois que là il ya une
déviation qui n'apportent pas plus de
bonheur mais beaucoup plus angoissant le
souhaitent ce biologiste inquiet une
réflexion internationale et une pause
dans les recherches mais tous les
biologistes sont loin d'être de son avis
deux organisations ont revendiqué la
responsabilité de l'attentât commis dans
le bureau de poste de l'hôtel de ville
de paris hier soir cet attentat a fait
un mort
et 18 blessés l'organisation des
partisans du droit et de la liberté
c'est tout d'abord manifestée à beyrouth
pour revendiquer cette action terroriste
et c'est également à beyrouth que le
comité de solidarité avec les
prisonniers politiques arabes et du
proche orient a publié un communiqué de
revendication commentaires pascal les
champs de revendications pour un même
attentat deux organisations dont l'une
était jusque là totalement inconnu ses
partisans du droit et de la liberté qui
revendiquent tous les attentats commis
en france depuis celui des galeries
lafayette en décembre 85 jusqu'à
l'attentât manqué de la gare de lyon et
tous ceux qui se produiront dans
l'avenir une série revendiqué jusque-là
par le cfppa
le comité de solidarité avec les
prisonniers politiques arabes et du
proche orient
auteur du deuxième communiqué de la
journée huit attentats au total qui ont
fait trois morts et 86 blessés
plus trois attentats manqués dans le rer
ou à la tour eiffel
chaque fois le cfppa réclame la
libération de trois terroristes détenus
en france
georges ibrahim abdallah anis naccache
eva rhodes jean darby djian pour les
enquêteurs aujourd'hui une certitude les
mêmes explosifs ont été utilisés dans
tous ces attentats
on peut donc les attribuer à une seule
organisation
oui mais laquelle le cfppa où les
partisans de la liberté
à moins que les deux cibles recouvre les
mêmes éléments terroristes
d'une part les deux textes de
revendication ont été reçus à beyrouth
et d'autre part les deux organisations
semblent poursuivre le même but
le pdl affirme lutter pour tous les
militants détenus dans les prisons des
ennemis de la liberté à paris en fin
d'après-midi la licra ligue contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
sos racisme le mrap notamment appelaient
à manifester
plusieurs organisations syndicats partis
étaient présents directement représenter
ou non dans ce défilé de protestation
contre tous les terrorismes qui se cache
derrière de grandes causes pour
justifier des actes de barbarie c'est
une phrase extraite de l'appel à la
manifestation
le secrétaire d'état aux droits de
l'homme claude manu ura était parmi les
manifestants à ses côtés jean poperen
michel rocard ou encore jean tiberi du
rpr
dès hier soir le président de la
république adressé au maire de paris
jacques chirac un télégramme afin qu'ils
transmettent à la population parisienne
à ses élus et plus particulièrement aux
familles des victimes
l'expression de sa peine et de sa
solidarité nous devons tous témoigné de
la résolution du pays de combattre sans
merci de terrorisme qui menace tant de
vies et nos libertés
ce texte du président de la république
est largement repris sous des formes
différentes par les principaux
responsables des partis politiques
français de laurent fabius à raymond
barre de valéry giscard d'estaing lionel
jospin alors contre le terrorisme la
marge est étroite et favorise le
consensus paul amar c'est vraie cohésion
rassemblement solidarité unités voilà
les mots qui reviennent le plus souvent
dans les déclarations politiques de tous
bords une telle unanimité quelques
exceptions près rares en france
elle méritait d'être relevé notre
propension à polémiquer tels que cette
succession d'attentats sanglants aurait
pu provoquer un débat franco français un
débat dans notre pays est si friand ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et cela
doit pour le moins surprendre j'allais
dire décevoir les poseurs de bombes qui
connaissent très bien le fonctionnement
des démocraties occidentales et qui
espèrent en semant la terreur nous
diviser pour mieux nous affaiblir
ils n'y sont pas parvenus du moins pour
l'instant il faut s'en féliciter
mais il faut aussi savoir que cet échec
relatif peut les conduire à être encore
plus odieux en clair d'autres attentats
pourraient se produire comme ils se sont
produits avant 80 copernic avant mars 86
la rue des rosiers
après mars 86 l'hôtel de ville aucun
gouvernement n'a été ou ne sera épargné
ce triste constat rend donc dérisoire
toute controverse politique
il n'y a plus de clivage gauche droite
quand ces hommes venus d'ailleurs nous
déclare la guerre
encore faut-il maintenant trouver une
réponse commune à ce fléau second livre
c'est le dernier rapport de la haute
autorité de la communication
audiovisuelle c'est son quatrième mais
ce sera son dernier rapport avec des
bons et des mauvais points et le souhait
que le principe d'une égalité de
contraintes entre télévision publique et
privée soit respectée la haute autorité
sera bientôt théoriquement remplacé par
la commission nationale de la
communication et des libertés
prévue par la loi léotard michèle cotta
n'a pas attendu nommé en août 82 par le
président françois mitterrand elle a
démissionné de ses fonctions
comment
gaël monfils c'était sa dernière
représentation elle était encore la
présidente et fêtait ce matin ses quatre
ans d'exercice à la tête de la haute
autorité
toutes les personnalités du monde
audiovisuel étaient venus rendre un
hommage amical à celle qui était la
garante de leur indépendance et de leur
liberté pendant quatre ans au sein d'un
paysage audiovisuel en pleine mutation à
un poste éminemment politique
michèle cotta a joué son rôle avec
fermeté et diplomatie respect du
pluralisme harmonie des programmes
nomination des présidents de chaînes
elle a beaucoup contribué à l'évolution
de la télévision
je crois que la haute autorité a été
conçu comme un élément de rempart entre
le pouvoir politique et l'audiovisuel et
je crois que c'est une bonne chose qu'en
attendant l'action de la haute autorité
qui n'a pas été contestée est une action
qui a fait progresser est ce qu'on peut
appeler la démocratie audiovisuelle en
france
c'est une recherche permanente de l'
équilibre et je dirais du consensus
or c'est vrai que c'est difficile c'est
vrai que les téléspectateurs souvent
pense que les choses sont orientés et
des rames chacun un peu tendance à
entendre midi à sa porte et à voir midi
à sa porte
nous avons essayé de rendre la
télévision tous français est-ce que nous
sommes arrivés ça c'est selon du sort
plutôt mieux arriver canon sortie en
beauté et en douceur pour la présidente
qui boucle ses cartons elle sera
remplacé par marc payet qui devrait
assurer l'intérim pendant quelques
semaines
on attend l'avis du conseil
constitutionnel sur la nouvelle loi puis
la nouvelle commission se mettra en
place
le chancelier ouest allemand helmut kohl
et le premier ministre jacques chirac on
tue un long entretien en fin d'après
midi le premier du genre pour discuter
économie agriculture mais aussi sécurité
jacques chirac and co ne se
connaissaient pas bien commentaires
michel meyer qu'après une visite de
courtoisie au président mitterrand que
le chancelier kohl a enfin trouvé le
chemin de matignon habitué à
l'interlocuteur privilégié françois
mitterrand helmut kohl avait donné
l'impression d'un peu négligé jacques
chirac on pouvait douter que le
chancelier allemand et ses conseillers
surtout est assimilé le mode d'emploi et
les usages de la cohabitation à la
française cela semble être le cas
maintenant les gouvernants de wons
discute donc directement au sommet sur
le fond les dossiers clefs du franco
allemand avec le chef de l'exécutif
français sur la sellette le terrorisme
actualité oblige on attend une
initiative la coopération militaire et
industriel bien sûr thème quasi
permanent de ce type de rencontre des
dossiers plus délicats sont également au
programme
cattenom la politique nucléaire
française qui inquiète l'opinion
publique reste allemande ce qui à
linverse irrite à paris la politique
économique et monétaire également
harmonisation souhaitait de part et
d'autre il ne faudrait pas que la
stupéfiante spectaculaire prospérité
allemande
à l'heure actuelle avec des excédents
record dans l'après-guerre se fasse trop
aux dépens de la politique économique
française
à cet égard paris attendu helmut kohl un
geste sur le plan des taux d'intérêt on
ne souhaite pas en effet à paris que la
spéculation internationale à la hausse
ne se fixe à plus ou moins court terme
sur le deuil marques comme ce fut
souvent le cas dans le passé égyptiens
et israéliens poursuivent leurs
négociations sur le problème de
l'enclavement de tabac un territoire
d'un kilomètre carré occupé par israël
et revendiquées par l'egypte sur le
golfe d'aqaba un sommet egypte israël
est prévu en cas de réussite mais
l'attentât terroriste commis contre la
synagogue d'istanbul pourrait peser sur
l'attitude israélienne commentaires
charles enderlin correspondant d'antenne
2 à jérusalem
ces deux kilomètres carrés de plage à
tabac au sud des lattes constitue le
principal obstacle au sommet perez
moubarak
les deux pays revendiquent cette enclave
et négocier un arbitrage depuis plus
d'un an
la controverse ne porte plus que sur une
borne frontière
un différend de 58 mètres carrés deux
points de 58 mètres carrés c'est un
obstacle qu'on pourra surmonter pour
arriver à ce dialogue important n'y a
pas d'assurance en ce moment tabac c'est
le seul point de divergence est ce qu'il
ya d'autres raisons
non je crois que tabassé le point de
divergence il faut arriver à un accord
sur le cette question de tabac pour
commencer vraiment un dialogue sur des
questions beaucoup plus large beaucoup
plus importante peut-être qui concerne
les relations entre les deux pays et le
processus de paix au moyen-orient en
fait tente à jérusalem cocker on craint
que l'annulation du sommet perez
moubarak entraîne une nouvelle
détérioration des relations entre les
deux pays
cela alors que la tension monte au
proche-orient à là suite les derniers
attentats et de l'éventualité de raids
de représailles israéliens
les négociations qui se poursuivent au
caire sur tabac sont peut être celle de
la dernière chance pour le processus de
paix
anatoly france qui est à paris il doit
participer à la réunion du conseil
international de la conférence mondiale
pour les juifs du rss anatolie star ans
qui a été reçu par le président de la
république aujourd'hui président qui l'a
remercié de l'est qui fut pas apporter
ainsi que sa femme
un atelier star ans qui est notre invité
ce soir bonsoir je vais tout d'abord
vous inviter à regarder des images des
images de votre échange c'était au mois
de février dernier
votre retour je suis échangé contre des
espions regarder avec nous puis je vous
demanderai votre réaction six mois après
un petit homme coiffé d'une immense choc
qu'a ainsi nous a paru il ya sept mois
chan ce qui libérerait des camps
soviétiques après neuf ans de détention
neuf ans sous le fallacieux prétexte
d'espionnage alors que son vrai crime
était de militer pour les refuzniks il
voulait que les juifs soviétiques puisse
aller en israël
il voulait y aller lui-même il y est
enfin arrivé en partie grâce au courage
de sa femme avital tient couru le monde
entier pour plaider sa cour
il y a été accueilli en triomphateur par
toute la classe politique de perez à
shamir en passant par ariel sharon
dernière victoire sa mère et quelques
proches parents devaient à leur tour les
rejoindre il ya quelques jours
la distance qui six mois après comment
vous percevez ce retour quel a été le
cheminement vous avez fait depuis six
mois je vois cela maintenant c'était des
moments très émouvants au kgb on m'a mis
des vêtements de civils
on m'a mis des pantalons beaucoup trop
grand qui glissait on m'a emmené à
berlin en citant la échanger ensuite à
francfort j'ai rencontré ma femme je
sais à berne israël
j'ai rencontré mon peuple mater en
quelques heures toutes ces heures
lorsque je volais lorsque je suis arrivé
en israël
je suis arrivé en pleurant c'était
extrêmement émouvant et même après
j'avais toujours peur j'avais peur de me
réveiller de ce rêve et je pense que
cette peur a duré plus d'un mois
maintenant je sais avec assurance que je
ne révèlerai pas et que les cauchemars
ne reviendront plus les souvenirs du
cachot cependant quand je me souviens de
la russie mais je me souviens de ce que
j ai laissé là-bas et j'espère qu'ils
connaîtront la même libération que la
mienne ski votre libération votre cas la
libération également de membres de votre
famille prouve que le régime soviétique
est en train de changer que l'arrivée de
mikhaïl gorbatchev a modifié les données
intérieur de la politique soviétique
c'est un dirigeant qui comprend beaucoup
mieux la psychologie des dirigeants
occidentaux et de l'ouest en général qui
est à déconseiller qui ont vécu toute
leur vie à l'ouest
il essaye avec l'aide de certains gestes
qui ont beaucoup d'effets de créer une
nouvelle image à l'ouest sans régler les
problèmes sur le fond lorsque l'on m'a
libéré la situation des droits de
l'homme en urss et surtout des murs
étaient en train de s'aggraver
il y avait une nouvelle médiation
toujours des discriminations à l'égard
des juifs soviétiques notamment des
universités d'un certain de lieux
tout d'abord cette politique de
discrimination du continue ensuite
l'immigration presque entièrement cessé
les juifs surtout ensuite ceux qui ont
demandé un visa pour israël sont dans
une crise est content qu'on ait ces
conditions très difficiles après ma
libération il ya eu des arrestations des
répressions qui ont touché même salle
des simples professeur d'hébreu
aujourd'hui j'ai dit monsieur mitterrand
je lui ai donné une lettre d'une
personne qui depuis 20 ans essaye de
pouvoir partir en israël alors que
gorbatchev disait lui-même à la presse
française qu'il n'y a pas un seul homme
qui soit dans cet état d'attentes pour
sortir du pays allaient en israël il ya
beaucoup de milliers de refuse nique des
prisonniers et 4000 personnes qui ne
peuvent même pas faire la demande de
visa
vous avez un chiffre à nous donner sur
le nombre de personnes qui souhaitent
immigrer de près vous d'abord il est un
chiffre très simple
combien de personnes ont demandé des la
possibilité à israël l'union soviétique
elle n'a pas donné ses visas donc 390
mille personnes en fait demandé
simplement immigrés c'est déjà à courir
un certain risque ensuite environ 40000
personnes ont déjà eu un refus se sont
vu refuser cette possibilité des
migrations et il ya environ dix mille
familles séparées
quelques dizaines de personnes qui sont
en prison seulement pour avoir exprimé
le souhait des migrants israël ou avoir
enseigné l'hébreu merci à notre histoire
ce qui vous avait décidé de changer
votre nom quand vous êtes arrivé en
israël vous appeler maintenant nathan
sharansky pourquoi il ya quelques années
tous ceux qui luttaient pour pouvoir
partir en israël et bien nous avons
commencé à prendre des prénoms hébreu et
moi j'ai choisi le nom nhat hanh
c'est-à-dire dans toute famille et
assimilés on n'utilise pas un nom hébreu
on a donc appelé anatolie mais depuis
longtemps on m'appelait nhat hanh
et c'est pourquoi j'ai pris ce nom une
fois arrivé en israël renonce à ma femme
sites appelés à vital merci aux échanges
qui devrait été notre notre invité je
signais simplement pour ceux qui
voudraient vous entendrez vous
rencontrez que vous serez jeudi soir au
cirque d'hiver à paris pour une réunion
de solidarité
merci inculpation du fonctionnaire
soviétique des nations unies guennadi
zakharov arrêté le 23 août dernier à new
york
inculpation conspiration pour avoir
communiqué des documents une puissance
étrangère
benazir buttho a été libéré avec la
principale dirigeante de l'opposition
pakistanaise remise en liberté après 26
jours de prison une centaine de
personnes ont été également libérés par
le gouvernement du général zia collision
entre deux navires au large de port
harcourt dans le sud du nigeria
il y aurait mais c'est un bilan
provisoire une centaine de morts en
afrique du sud trois membres du congrès
national africain le mouvement anti
apartheid ont été pendus ce matin al
à pretoria il avait été condamné à mort
pour meurtre le ministère des affaires
étrangères français a regretté que les
appels à la clémence n'aient pas été
entendus
au chili un journaliste travaillant dans
une revue d'opposition a été retrouvée
assassinée dans un faubourg de santiago
plusieurs dirigeants de l'opposition ont
été arrêtés ainsi des prêtres français
qui pourraient être libérés
prochainement
peu avant un grand rassemblement des
partisans de pinochet à santiago du
chili
voici le reportage réalisé par nos
envoyés spéciaux bernard benyamin genre
est cet été hier après midi en plein
centre de santiago des étudiants était
venu remettre une lettre à l'ambassade
de hollande afin de dénoncer la
situation au chili
le problème c'est que cette démarche
intervenue au lendemain de l'attentât
manqué contre le général pinochet
très vite ils se sont retrouvés
prisonniers dans leur voiture
encerclé par des carabiniers mais aussi
par des civils
nombre de la sécurité nationale la tente
a duré quelques minutes
et puis avec une extrême violence ils
ont été arrêtés
une femme qui n'est pas il faut le
souligner le visage qu'offre aujourd'hui
santiago mais qui témoignent des
méthodes utilisées par la police
chilienne
pendant l'état de siège ce matin en tout
cas une messe était célébrée à la
mémoire des quatre soldats et du
carabiniers nous or pendant l'attentât
de dimanche soir la cérémonie avait lieu
dans l'une des cours de l'école
militaire en présence de la famille des
disparus de la notion bien sûr mais
surtout on remarquer au premier rang le
général pinochet
ainsi que toute la junte militaire
si tu reste l'une des premières
conséquences de l'attentât manqué les
forces armées chiliennes sont
aujourd'hui plus unis que jamais les
déclarations de militaires qui se
succèdent depuis deux jours sont sur ce
point très clair le régime est décidé à
poursuivre sa mission jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire selon les propres mots du
général pinochet extirper le communisme
du chili autant dire que le pays
s'apprête à vivre encore des moments
difficiles
la cérémonie terminée le général
pinochet va regagner le palais de la
moneda et dans une heure vers 15h de
santiago il présidera une marche de
plusieurs milliers de personnes venus
lui apporter leur soutien après
l'attentât de dimanche soir ce sera
l'autre moment fort de la journée en
encodant tout le pays et en raison de
l'état de siège
les arrestations se multiplient
manifestation à paris à l'appel de la
cgt défense de l'emploi appel à l'action
c'est lé thème du discours de rentrée du
secrétaire général henri krasucki
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
défilé en conspuant notamment le
ministre des affaires sociales philippe
seguin dans les classiques qui a reconnu
la franchise exceptionnelle du ministre
avoue ans selon lui que le capitalisme
était incapable de faire reculer le
chômage
la confédération cfdt soulignait d'autre
part l'écart important entre la
politique gouvernementale sur l'emploi
et ses propositions la cdt tenait une
conférence de presse de rentrée
également un groupe d'hommes armés a
réussi à délivrer cet après midi un
détenu soigné à l'hôpital de la pitié
d'un 13e arrondissement de paris le
détenu et ses complices ont réussi à
s'enfuir à deauville ont dit vive le
cinéma américain le festival qui lui est
consacrée connaît désormais un bon
succès ce soir un sim coproduit par
antenne 2 je hais les acteurs en direct
à deauville
jean jacques dufour wicklow tout à
l'heure on va projeter le talking trempé
du festival américain de deauville jeu
et les acteurs tiré d'un roman du
scénariste ben hech c'est le premier
long métrage de gérard aqsiq un jeune
réalisateur
l'action de ce film coproduit par
antenne 2 se situe dans l' usine à rêves
hollywoodienne en 42 à ce propos ce film
est en noir et blanc sous titré en
anglais pour vous mettre dans l'ambiance
un extrait où michel blanc qui nous
rejoint ici là vous mettez là où il ya
la petite croix michel blanc donc qui
joue les fakirs devient le tube
d'aspirine ambulant de jean poiret un
agent artistique
il déteste les comédiens la soeur
s'appelle cas roma vous avez mal à la
tête
des pics à glace et où il enlevait en un
instant par osmose
et
douleur at elle disparu depuis dix ans
c'est extraordinaire je la tête tout
dégager plus à moindre trace de migraine
est une science orientale que je suis
disposé à enseigner à toutes les
personnes que cela intéresse moyennant
une somme modique
oui alors dans ce film là vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de dialogues mais vous êtes
fait un masque
oui mais c'est à dire j'ai pas beaucoup
de présence non plus parce que il m'a
donné un rôle assez court mais j'en ai
profité pour me faire une tête
tous les acteurs sont un peu dingue est
ce qu'à votre avis c'est l'idée que vous
faisiez de hollywood de ces années là je
pense qu'il y avait je pense qu'il y
avait effectivement peut-être une
fantaisie une folie une des mesures qui
n'existe plus au temps maintenant la
notion de stars a quand même beaucoup
changé je pense qu'ils avaient une
fantaisie mais il ya surtout une
fantaisie dans la tête de bénesse
l'auteur de deux du scénario inverse du
roman est bon c'est un peu une seconde
est une caricature alors à propos de
l'hystérie qui règne parmi les
personnages vais proposer de regarder
comment galabru veut convaincre qu'il
est encore jeune pour avoir un rôle
un homme de 50 ans aurait-il pu faire ça
ou ça pousse à paul et écouter la rue ce
remake de fils du destin et une affaire
de 3,19 dollars il leur faut des
beurettes deniz wald gens vous la corde
est mauvais mais c'est une vedette comme
elvina bliss et johnny jones c'est
laurence pison voilà dites moi on était
un peu lent on est en direct ben dites
moi vous alors vous avez fait ce film
vous permettait à un beau numéro
d'acteur à tous vos comédiens
ah oui je crois que c'est vraiment
l'essentiel c'est le plus grand plaisir
c'est de les voir jouer quoi dans ce
film est pour moi j'étais le premier
spectateur donc j'ai passé un très bon
moment j'espère que les spectateurs ont
pas soin nous ciblons - dites-moi est-ce
que vous vous seriez prête dans 30 ans à
faire le genre d'acrobaties que fait
galabru pour avoir un rôle d'écouté j'ai
pas le physique ingrat de ce garçon déjà
qui fait rire même même sens en faire
des acrobaties mais j'espère que mes mon
arthrose me permettra de sautiller
encore gaiement et est-ce que vous
pensez que vos agents ont des raisons
que vous détestez vous en général les
comédiens annoncé ça sera plutôt l
inverse
à vrai dire mais
mais non tout va bien tout va bien c'est
de la comédie c'est d'excentricité ces
deux comment dire quoi une sorte de
caricature très sympathique quand même
du milieu
sinon ça n'aurait aucun intérêt que vous
auriez aimé être une star à hollywood
dans les années 40
déjà je vais mettre une star tout court
et hollywood dans les années 40
encore encore plus mais la vraie vrai de
vrai oui vous êtes une star dominique
vallée pour bien me le dire bon enfin
tout ce qu'on peut dire donc on va
laisser rentrer tous les artistes qui
sont là dans la salle on peut souhaiter
une bonne soirée aux spectateurs qui
vont assister à la projection de ce film
et on peut dire aussi pour ceux qui
aiment les numéros d'acteurs c'est
vraiment un film très amusant merci jean
jacques on reparlera du festival de
deauville dans mardi cinéma juste après
ce journal demain soir c'est du sport
ces dernières informations sportives de
cette édition demain soir france islande
en football pour les éliminatoires du
championnat d'europe des nations 88
pas de surprise dans la composition de
l'équipe de france mais les débuts de
stéphane paille aux côtés de stopyra
dans l'attaqué française et puis pour la
météo leur ambition et oui avec une
journée typique d'une belle arrière
saison du soleil beaucoup de soleil à
peine perturbée par quelques petites
bruines matinée cela dit il nous faut
quand même parler des nuages ce que l'on
voit sur la photo satellite
il était aujourd'hui sur l'est sur
l'extrême sud est du pays ils vont
s'éloigner y en aura encore demain sur
la corse avec des risques d'orages
et puis il était sur l'espagne alors
poussé par des vents d'ouest et un petit
peu de sud ouest et bien ils vont venir
recouvrir demain toutes les pyrénées
toutes les régions allant du pays basque
pratiquement aux pyrénées-orientales
arrière ce sera du beau temps regardez
la carte du temps prévu pour demain
c'est admira pour début septembre
puis le soleil presque partout je
voulais quelques brumes le matin qui
vont lui de se dissiper par contre par
contre sur les pyrénées un temps gris
peu ou pas de précipitations c'est déjà
ça alors qu'en revanche sur la corse il
y aura moins de nuages mais par contre
il y aura des orages qui pourront être
assez violent comme toute façon de toute
façon c'est plutôt du beau temps pour
demain côté température et bien elles
sont stationnaires elles sont tout à
fait normale elle aussi de 17 à 20 et
même 21 degrés 21 degrés à paris pas de
problème de ce côté-là et de 22 jusqu'à
25 et même 30 degrés sur la moitié sud
30 degrés à nîmes 30 degrés à marseille
voyez des températures qui sont dignes
de cette fin d'été pour terminer je vous
dirais que demain il fera 17 degrés à
bruxelles et 26 à jérusalem contamine
encore une fois avec notre agenda
demain ce sera le mercredi 10 septembre
le soleil se lèvera 7h20 tu ne coucheras
un top 14 quatre minutes de soleil en
moins nous fêterons les inez puisque ce
sera la sentinelle et à partir de demain
vous pourrez trouver ce livre qui est
tout à fait remarquable est presque
indispensable si l'on veut connaître
l'état du monde l'état du monde 86 c'est
la sixième année de cette production des
éditions la découverte c'est un annuaire
économique et géopolitique mondiale
sixième année je vous le recommande
l'état du monde 86 à 23h35 philippe
harrouard présentera la dernière édition
du journal d'antenne 2 à demain 20h
bonsoir merci